my kid air yeah is there me okay I hear
you what do you what are you on what do
you and you got a soup can phone it's
it's um it's a string attached to a
coconut like on Gilligan's Island okay
all right Mike thank you for calling it
charlie real quick I got some wrong
people the best pillows all right please
send me to Dolphin okay
that team is vastly underrated they went
to people forget they went to three
straight Super Bowl they lost down first
100 X 2 and Mercury Moors is one of
those underrated players in history I
wrote a book on ascending to dolphins
not to do singles Paul but very very
good there's no question the best team
the Bears they thought Bears team would
destroy anybody Michael any body that
defense was so revolutionary the
coaching there was so revolutionary and
it was just that they were a fierce
devastating thing that could compete
with anybody you gotta go with them no
number one no question well I have no
problem with that take I have no problem
with that answer I just had a problem
with the fact that my man Brockman even
tried to stuff in the 2007 New England
Paige ha's but that's neither here nor
there
listen Mike I got a couple of questions
for you Jake color why is he back in the
NFL and do you agree with me on the fact
that fox broadcasting are the real
winners here the fact that you're never
going to hear Jay Keller call a game are
they the winners or the Miami Dolphins
the winners and who's the loser here
well I think the loser is is Colin
Kaepernick because he should be in the
league he's I could name I could go down
a list of teams not just quarterback
he's better than but but but entire
quarterback staffs the whole quarterback
group that he's better than and he's
clearly being uh blackballed by the
league so he's he's he's the loser but
he shouldn't be being a link but the
coupler thing was amazing like I get the
whole he's
the system my ego gave you know that
system uh I think some of that is often
over blown because if you turn the ball
over a lot it blows up the system right
and and I know Cutler has worked with
him and Cutler had a good season under
him but people were acting like Adam
GaSe is like Bill Walsh
I mean calm down and you you have Jay
Cutler who offense he's just not good he
was one all over constantly he was one
in four last year I don't know what the
exact like uh you know Tom Brady retired
and he came out as oh god gee colors
back and they paid him ten dollars he
paid him ten million dollars and he woke
up this morning and he said he didn't
know where he was in his hotel room and
if it is the thing like he he for all
the narratives about Colin it's funny
because Cutler sort of fits all the
narratives that column doesn't like
people were saying Colin doesn't work
hard
Oh Cutler's notorious for not doing that
Colin doesn't call wanted too much money
well JJ's got ten barrel ten million
dollars it's all the things that that
people are saying privately or that
people don't like a Catholic people are
saying publicly um a lot of it fits with
Cutler's a weird thing and look it could
work it could work because Gates is very
good at some food is the only coach
really that was able to get Cutler to
sort of not be Cutler to be a
professional quarterback to study to not
throw interceptions not going to bowl so
it's possible it could work but it still
take cover I think they will be better
with Kaepernick but I'm one of the few
people out loan people out there but
it's going to be an interesting thing to
watch all right Mike Freeman is on the
phone this is Michael Rapaport what's
going on in Dallas Ezekiel Elliott
investigation not investigation how's
this going to play out and and why does
the NFL take so long to finish out these
things and work these things out or is
that a good thing what's the status of
Zeke it's a it's a thing that a lot of
people were on the league or asking the
Kyle
boys are asking it why is taking so long
and it's the NFL a tough spot Michael I
mean if they take too short they're
criticizing to to only criticize there's
no question I've gone on a really really
lengthy a long time and that tends to
point to a Ezekiel earlier being a
little bit of trouble I can't imagine a
league would take this much time and
then not do anything now the Cowboys are
convinced that he did nothing wrong and
he's going to be he's going to they're
not he's not getting punished but I find
that hard to believe
I think you're going to look at some
time you go see some type of suspected I
think it's going to finally happen
pretty soon but it does mean you know
Cowboys are right when they say this
whole investigatory process needs to be
fixed because it it they could probably
streamline this but at least they're
doing this one thing I want people to
remember is just where we were not long
ago angry but cases like Ray Rice other
cases they worked as faster and now the
league is seriously sort of looking at
this it's not perfect a lot of flaws
still but they're at least trying to
sort of look into this kind of stuff
applauded I agree I agree you can't win
you can't win with these things if it's
too fast it's too fast if it's too slow
it's getting dragged out um Mike Freeman
on the phone here with Michael Rapaport
Rich Eisen show Sheldon Richardson
talking about my man Brandon Marceau I'm
a huge Brandon Marshall fan when he was
with the Jets I think he's going to be
dominant this year I think that he's
going to bring so much of that Jets oil
at the Giants offense he's going to
bring so much to Odell Beckham because
the fact that you you can't you're not
going to double-team Brandon Marshall
but you're not going to leave him alone
why does Brandon Marshall have a bad
reputation
why why why is why are they talking
greasy about my man B Marsh because be
MRSA he's my guy he he's come a long way
as you know Mike I agree from yeah he's
really dealt with mental health issues
in a really brave great way that will
help
a lot of people and has helped a lot of
people he just in the jet I mean it's
just a disaster and he was as part of
that disaster and some people in the
locker our own shelter being one of them
buildings pointing fingers too much but
the overall point you make is right he's
going to go to he's going to go to the
Giants
uh if you playing fantasy takeover back
at number one in your dress number one
he's going to take so much pressure off
of Beckham you saw some of that last
year where Kings are really starting to
figure out a little bit some of hotel's
tendencies and traits a little group
he's getting a lot more attention than
normal he still had a great season but
you saw the league not figuring him out
but figuring out how to slow down a
little bit and I think what Marshall
will do is open things wide open again
he's not like you say he's not gonna get
double-teamed Marshall but he's got to
draw a lot of defensive attention
because he's still very good he's still
very talented receiver he's going to
open things up for Beckham I think back
was going to have a massive massive
table high I agree and I think Brandon
Marshall is going to have a massive
massive season and and the year before
last what was that I don't do math Mike
we're talking about 2007 life with the
New York Jets
Brandon Marshall I had some sort of
record-breaking season last year they
had my podiatrist who are backing at
times and this year again we talked
about Kaepernick you got Christian the
hack Hackenberg Bryce petty Josh McCowan
duking it out and Colin Kaepernick
doesn't get a job I mean this is a joke
this is a joke joke and this little Jets
have your podiatrist podiatrist yeah my
podiatrist played Queen took snaps and
games last year it's bad I mean I
thought of capita I wouldn't go to the
chest but I mean you've heard of jets
you should've at least spoken to him I
mean he's so much he's better than every
quarterback on a roster by a mile
and he could actually you you put him
there there's no talent around a
necessarily but he will make things
interesting and fun
to watch if we most fans will be more
interested in watching
but that owner will never do it you will
never do it
what's the owner's name ah
Oh Jim I stopped over Woody Hayes what
are you sure I know this very rich it is
no lips
he's very we're rich but for some reason
is no lips great guy let me into the
Suites at the Jets just games great
family nice guy who's going to win the
Rookie of the Year this year Mike oh wow
we're going to be the contenders is
there going to be a dak Prescott in a Z
Kelly eight because they're going to be
guys that are really breakthrough
rookies this season well I don't know
that I almost done press car last year
and I couldn't believe what I was
watching I mean I saw God very early on
who was just gonna really you could see
they digested everything really well and
he was just going to be a great great
player and I think that's going to
continue this you're going to see him
really evoke because he studies he
studies hard he takes it very seriously
so capita does by the way studies where
your heart is still working out um so
you're going to see I don't know if
you're gonna see any kind of quarterback
like that but people decide the ball is
kind of way to look for some bookie
prominence and there's some guys that
can that can scare you a little bit and
maybe win the award to speak in there
but it's you think about this coming
season everything's gonna sort of to me
the whole season is about the Patriots I
know it sorry Mike
I'm sorry no what do you mean you think
they're gonna go 19a no again at cuz it
ain't happenin my friend it's not 19 ago
but well there's so great ones they go
19 I know since they're so great they
might Michael they might they might I
mean I've never seen a team that was
already so good and an add to the pieces
they've added yeah it's crazy
and they got a chance to be I mean it's
gonna be scary
they're going to be the Dom to me
they're going to be the dominant story
this year maybe not 19 another but and
one of the houses that decision is so
awful to go in a letter can sort of
damage them and slow them down so that
crews through that division and get
home-field advantage and then they're
hard to beat there so they're going to
be in the other guy the other guy to
watch too is Aaron Rodgers you could
have it as storks even you could easily
see a Packers Patriot Subaru oh that
would be good that would be good listen
I can't argue with you about about the
Patriots as much as they drive me nuts I
have tremendous you can't argue is how
great they are
um and what can I say what about
McCaffrey how good is he going to be
this year
McCaffrey yep I think he's going to be
we're talking about Rookie of the Year
he's one of God that'll be in and he he
gives that team something haven't had a
while which is just sort of a very sort
of God comes out of the backfield
catches all well and is quick and it's
going to take the Panthers are finally
saying I'll believe it when I see it but
they're finally saying they're going to
stop just really pounding Cam Newton
running him a lot and they're going to
give it more to McCaffrey's on the other
guys in the backfield
I believe it when I say it right because
Camden is just too great a weapon and
they rely on him so much to run the ball
but the Catholic it takes a pressure off
him so that's either God really look out
for each other
I've looked over here but I was just
impact on that team they're going to do
- alright Mike Freeman thank you for
calling in I appreciate you taking the
time I appreciate the insight and I
appreciate you the reality check for
Brockman that the New England Patriots
of 2007 you got it you got to be the
best know the best it don't mean a thing
it always got that ring do not do that
do that tonight yeah Mike thank you for
calling in I appreciate it thank you
appreciate it Mike Freeman the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy